bonjour antoine bonjour ravi de vous
avoir sur sur ce plateau d'arreter
france les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle qui affinent leurs
propositions en matière de sécurité
antoine vous avez enquêté justement sur
ces différents projets sur notre site
internet rt france point tv et vous nous
en présenter quelques quelques unes
aujourd'hui deux dossiers alors
aujourd'hui on va présenter les deux
projets qu'on a choisie c'est-à-dire
valérie pécresse et yannick jadot donc
bien côté la formation des élèves
d'autres côté saad est élevé alors si on
revient un petit peu en arrière de
quelques semaines par exemple au moment
de la galette des rois d'un côté pour
les mrc le kärcher
c'est plutôt conservateur
on parle de retour à l'autorité de
l'autre côté chez yannick jadot s'est
pas forcément une question qui est
prioritaire mais il en a quand même un
petit peu parlé on y prend on pense chez
eux par exemple s'est élevé à légaliser
le cannabis
avec un programme plutôt progressiste
voire parfois libertaire et même un
petit peu suspicieux à l'égard des
fonctionnaires de police des forces de
l'ordre en général avec un contrôle
accru et une
une réforme du contrôle interne en fait
de la police et de la gendarmerie il ya
beaucoup de candidatures à gauche on l'a
vu comment est ce que la famille est
élevé par bintel à se distinguer alors
chez nick shadow c'est pas très facile
parce qu'en fait effectivement comme il
ya beaucoup de formations politiques à
gauche qui s'engagent sur la campagne
c'est un peu la cacophonie
il ya des choses qu'on retrouve un peu
partout c'est la notion de proximité la
proximité de la police la proximité de
la justice donc surtout dans les
formations de gauche il ya cette idée de
recruter par exemple 3000 magistrat qui
pour le coup se retrouvent sur tout le
spectre politique
ensuite on a l'idée aussi très commune
est répandu dans les formations de
gauche c'est-à-dire mettre fin au
contrôle jugé abusif contrôles au faciès
par exemple avec peut-être un
accroissement de la formation des
policiers ils seraient formés pendant
plus longtemps plus sensibilisés sur ces
questions là on à la fin du lb du
lanceur de balles de défense d'un duel
bd en manifestation ça c'est aussi très
commun aussi sur les réflexions sur les
grenades sur le grès lacrymogènes tout
ce qui vient autour du maintien de
l'ordre
et puis on a des pistes de réflexion
donc sur la légalisation du cannabis ça
il ya au moins deux formations
politiques qui en parlent actuellement
et puis un un nouvel axe qu'il irait en
utilisant en fait l'argent de la
répression contre le cannabis pour le
remettre dans la sensibilisation le
thérapeutique la prévention
ce qui différencie un petit peu le
problème le programme e élevé des de
celui des autres c'est sur la prison
c'est à dire plus tôt en matière de
justice que de police par exemple ils
ont une petite idée qui tranche un peu
c'est de laisser les personnes trans
choisir s'ils veulent être incarcéré
avec les hommes ou les femmes et puis
ils ont donné un chiffre pour une
cellule décente et digne c'est à dire
neuf mètres carrés par personne et les
républicains est ce qu'ils regardent la
concurrence alors valérie pécresse oui
bien sûr on regarde la confiance il a
même été dit au téléphone pendant que je
faisais cette enquête que tout le monde
courait après les idées d'un seul et
même candidat
ce qui n'est pas forcément vrai
d'ailleurs en matière de police une
source parlementaire donc qu'est proche
d'eric ciotti nous a expliqué que la
face du karcher en fait c'était pour
sortir de la longue séquence du passé
vaccinale dans laquelle l'opposition
commencé un petit peu à semble prouver
bizarrement envie de voilà de sortir de
cette espèce de transe l'a donc qu'ils
ont dit allez on va parler de karcher ça
va ça va mettre tout le monde un peu des
mots forts pour faire taire les
précédents qu en quelques sortes ils ont
un petit problème c'est qu'ils ont un
héritage nicolas sarkozy qui est
difficile à porter qui est très
critiquée même à l'intérieur de la
police que quoi qu'on dise les
républicains il ya la politique du
chiffre et à la police de proximité qui
a été cassée même si elle n'était pas
parfaite il ya les effectifs qui ont été
baissier pendant toute cette période où
il était ministre de l'intérieur puis
président de la république
donc pour pour contrer cet effet là ils
proposent les peines planchers une
réciprocité pénale plus forte un retour
de l'autorité en fait qu'il plaide pour
le retour de leur autorité là encore
c'est difficile de se distinguer pour
eux d'autres formations politiques de
droite puisque même par rapport au
gouvernement actuel
on a un peu l'impression que on leur a
coupé l'herbe sous le pied à certains
égards avec par exemple beauvau de la
sécurité la loi de sécurité globale et
la l'opmi donc cette loi programmation
qui va bientôt arriver sur le débat
public en mars on va suivre cela
évidemment il nous reste encore quelques
mois et évidemment pour voir le
programme des autres candidats je vous
renvoie je vous renvoie à notre site
internet arte france point tv merci
beaucoup antoine c'est pour pour toutes
ces précisions sur la question de la
sécurité dans la campagne présidentielle